pulled from the cabs of their trucks and
murdered in cold blood
their bodies left as a signal that a
bloody orgy of violence was guaranteed
it was the first indication to rescue
teams that the northern mozambique town
of palmer
was in the midst of an insurgent rampage
these pictures have never been seen
before were passed to sky news to show
what happened here
over the course of the past week and a
half and continues
fires burned across the town as
insurgent rebels
sacked military installations banks and
shops
the mozambican army was overwhelmed
attacked from
inside the town that had been
infiltrated for days
terrified civilians ran for cover in any
compound they could find
the private security company dag flew
helicopters in
to try and ferry them out to safety just
a few at a time
while the insurgents attacked and killed
the people praying for rescue fashion
messages on the ground
and that message was simple
expats and locals gathered here the
amarula hotel
rescue missions had started but out of
fuel the rescue teams had to pull off by
nightfall
alone and surrounded they organized a
convoy of at least a dozen cars to make
a break for the beach
exiting the front gate and turning right
they were immediately ambushed from the
trees across the road
they turned left and headed towards the
beach on this road
traveling at high speed they were
attacked again in the mayhem of this
flight for safety
only a handful of the vehicles made it
the dag teams searched for the cars
many were overturned and broken lying
off the roadside
amongst the dead was britain phil moore
his body
was finally retrieved
this was a sophisticated attack this
ship was grounded on the shore
as the attack started it's believed
insurgents had supplies on board
and returned continuously it was
attacked
as the tide came in and was left listing
and losing fuel
as the rescue teams continued their
search for survivors they were called in
to land by men in police uniforms
the pilots had doubts and came down away
from that landing zone
the men disappeared into woods nearby
dag believed it was an attempted ambush
by the insurgents
thousands have escaped from palmer on
local boats but hundreds are still
outside the heavily fortified oil
production base
owned by the french company total but
they aren't being allowed inside
the insurgents are still in the town
their positions
attacked near the water's edge
the insurgency here is three years old
but this
was an assault to send a message to the
mozambique government
that it's far from over stuart ramsey
sky news